der erste tag von mir in der
lindenstraße jetzt einen blick hinter
die kulissen in dem unter anderem die
frage besprochen wird kann ich bei
mutter beimer einziehen und wird sie
anfangen zu retten das und mehr jetzt im
lindenstraßen backstage video
es ist der 28 drehbeginn in der
lindenstraße und aber in der
lindenstraße haben wir den 17 juni dann
wird die folge ausgestrahlt das heißt
ich muss ob ich will oder nicht kurz
anleger händen tragen habt ihr stück mal
mitgenommen muss natürlich kariert sein
das wird gleich also ein brief an rund
zittern los geht's
also wie ihr seht wir sind mitten in der
lindenstraße und hier im astor da ist
alles verborgen das ist quasi jetzt hier
backstage littenstraße
hier gibt es ein café hab ich vorher
schon bekommen netterweise
so hier übrigens die galerie kommt
morgen
die galerie aller lindenstraßen
teilnehmer aber auch hier war irgendwo
auch til schweiger muss man mal zeigen
also nicht nur größer denn hier mache
doch irgendwo
til schweiger
hammer oder
da ist
so ich bin schon mal den cristo
morgen christoph 18
ich hoffe es nicht so viel zu tun bei
mir
okay ich hab schon falls dann
unter mir ist natürlich jetzt eine op
nötig aber
geht hier ganz schnell
sie wird ja
okay da gibt es richtig fotos wer wann
wie aussehen
durcheinander
einmal anbieten
ja denn und also lassen was man ganz
bisschen so vorsehen
überfällig die sensation war also so
schön wenn ich glaube ich immer nur bei
der linken schwarze aussehen
okay das ist das gute essen schlafen ja
ja
heute ausnahmsweise früher aufgestanden
und ich wollte eigentlich vernichtet
gehen aber ich muss sie gar nicht nein
nein nein nein aber es geht die chancen
nicht rein zu schauen das heißt ich
schaff das ich liege im bett und
irgendwie scheiße gut okay
für juni ist es ja ganz schön frisch
das ist juni die folge spielt am 17 juni
ach so
gut so
so weiterleben ihr setzt euch vorhin
dermaßen hin christoph setzte sich
hierhin case sich ok schon mal eure
interview sachen hier aus na ja also ich
nur gefilmt das wird alles 5 ich weiß
gar nicht wie alt die törtchen da schon
sind weiß jemand wie alt die törtchen
sind
aber trotzdem nicht zum verzehr
empfohlen
im interview was auch wenn man der macht
ja eben was zu wehren und es geht nicht
nur um das wie ist die lage satzes immer
so weit wie geht's dir alles in der
planung und dann fängst du los mit dem
satz so wie es die leer genauso
ist immer sofort ist alles gut ein
bisschen lärm bisschen länger vor dem
weseler wobei ich da relativ parallel
du kennst die erste frage wie die lage
genau und wie sie
ja und dann reden wir weiter sehr schön
naja ok
wer genau wissen möchte oder nicht je
nachdem wie war das in halo ist das doch
nicht gedacht und hier geht es weiter ab
dem moment wo wir hier sind und anstoßen
wirst du
glaubst und
grund und bitte ok du kennst du ja die
frage ist jetzt wie ist die lage ja wie
lange
warum
jetzt
wir machen uns berichten
wir gehen jetzt mit olli und jetzt
geht's um sam jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das
facebook und twitter voting hier zur
geltung kommt
genau ich habe mir kurz hallo ich bin
der christoph was auch ich sagte schon
hier wird seit jahren gehören die
internetgemeinde auf twitter und
facebook hat sich für dieses hemd
entschieden was sagst du
hermann
doch das findet er super wir können ja
noch mal fragen das ist wahrscheinlich
zu klein das ist
ja und das ist das könnte auch sein dass
noch gut okay so der regisseur guckt
jetzt gerade
hier in unserer aufnahme reihen ob alles
okay
okay also internetgemeinde hätten also
ich würde ja das einziehen einer nur das
frustrierend dass ziele wächst ja das
ist eine gute idee wenn man muss ja ein
bisschen herausforderung er könnte
schwarzmeer super
super ihr habt entschieden dieses
empfehle ich trage
ich glaube man sollte man die leute von
dem man sie erwartet sind schon diese
die mehrere brötchen kuchen uli ich
mache nichts aber ich habe jetzt ein
tennis haben ich mache immer solche
übungen
interessant machen das können wir jetzt
machen ist so viel sex wie achim hast du
jetzt eine halbe stunde ist hier
einrichten nein solange man nicht nein
wir machen nur kurz
ja ganz kurz ich weiß nicht ob du den
hintergrund kennt warum ich überhaupt
dieser sehne auftauchen
interview ja wir haben eine online
talkshow und den lindenstraße auf die
glorreiche idee gekommen wir wollen uns
mit der realen internetwelt auch
verknüpfen und ihnen interview ich
sowieso kay one
legendärer rapper in deutschland
wir machen im café
aber uns beide gibt es halt in
wirklichkeit und das ist ein bisschen
kleiner
tipp wenn mein sohn hier wäre jetzt
könnte er natürlich hätte er sofort ist
natürlich klar aber er wusste zahlen
also
ich denke trotzdem
schwer super
bowl in berlin meine hallo ich kommt
wird sich auf den guten
achten rang
jetzt müssen wir in kontakt kommt konrad
ich bin komparsen diese quasi wir nicht
ab da spricht so weil wir sprechen also
okay okay was schon sprechrolle ja ja ja
einmal wie es die lager und sensationell
und selbst wenn
statista ist der sagen kann in der
kneipe hier bei der ikk classic möchten
wir
ja sagt nur
wasser trinken und dann sagt ihr bier
schon mehr nein
ich mache mir jetzt ein t shirt ich bin
ein lindenstraßen star
ich habe einen satz gesagt
so also jetzt panik es geht ans et es
geht los war und
was jetzt mal nach draußen wie gesagt
juli aber es ist
28 februar eisig kalt
christoph ist die ganze zeit im bild das
bis zum ende der szene des sturmes
interviewen stunde peru
und
du kennst die erste frage
wie ist die lage
wie kommt
auf die hatte wieder aufnehmen
hintergrund aus dem orbit
ein bisschen offener bitte money
minimal hoffen noch ein bisschen
noch ein bisschen
achtung achtung
bitte
ok du kennst du eine erste frage wie ist
die lage versetzen wie kommt's ja
meine sehr verehrten damen jetzt wird
richtig aufwand getrieben weil jetzt
werden wir hier closed gedreht da wird
mal die lampe angeleuchtet und es ist
der hammer das ist der wahnsinn wer ganz
und das wird nachher ich sage also sage
und schreibe drei sekunden zu sehen sein
sage ich mal
das ist wirklich ein erhabenes gefühl
muss man sagen wir alles dreht sich
beide die wir eigentlich unsere cd
kommen wir zusammen
ich kann dich nicht sehen
danke
ich mache richtig geilen vorlauf super
ja du kennst meine erste frage wie ist
die lage wie ist die lage sensationell
wie kommt das letztmals gesehen vor zwei
jahren das mittlerweile bin ich fast
positiv mit einem klicks angekommen
aber du hast es ja nicht immer so viel
klingt wie www haben wir fix dabei ist
ja sein erstes album rausgebracht ich
glaube es liegt an klicks und dann mit
sicherheit auch das ist mir schon sehr
radikal wir halten das hat zu was mich
gern geschehen keine ursache
es ist mir eine ehre eine lösung dem tag
dabei
nie wissentlich wasser sensationelle ist
ja ich darf jetzt ab und zu mal
auftreten in der lindenstraße
ich mache ich mein schwiegersohn
könnte das sein
das kriegen wir noch hin oder her weil
ich sollte eigentlich in der wg
einziehen das hat aber nicht geklappt
weil wegen dass die disco wieder und
jetzt wo ich ihn noch ein zimmer oder
sowas aber ich habe bis jetzt immer ja
da muss ich mal gucken oder willst du da
einziehen naja ich werde hoffentlich um
es mit ihrer enkelin heiraten sondern
ein
wir begegneten sie trat mir auf jeden
fall begegnen immer ab und zu mal
gefreut nicht sie kann ja mal rein
platzen in interviews
es ist ja schon wieder wenn ich seinen
comics nächsten wasser planen ist darf
ich nicht sagen also piep piep piep piep
könnten wir zum beispiel auf der straße
ein konzert geben das könnte sein dass
ich mit meiner gruppe komme und dann
macht man konzern dann kommen sie dazu
und keine ahnung kamera
zum beispiel
das hat mich sehr gefreut ist das hat
mich sehr gefreut
das ist aber sehr lieben danke
ich jetzt mal daran und du danach ok
ich möchte euch mal was zeigen das ist
ja oliver von der presseabteilung der
hat uns nicht da gemacht das sind die
autogrammkarten von allen lindenstraßen
star heath ledger war übrigens auch
schon mal bei kriegst du ich weiß gar
nicht ob es auf youtube schon online
gestellt habe das ist der mann von frau
beimer also von von die heißen helga
beimer genau helga beimer und wann man
denn jetzt die helga die marie luise
marjan
es ist natürlich
hier haben wir hier übrigens unseren
retter
böse ihn ekici oder ekici das weiß
niemand weiß es ekici niemand weiß es
stimmt nicht allein sondern wo ist denn
marie luise marjan dies alle oder was
hier irene fischer ist die frau von hans
beimer heißt in ihrer rolle
anna ziegler genauso auch passaus und
jetzt muss ich mal in diesem winter ist
da ist mit autogramm hat sie schon
unterschrieben mutter beimer wir kennen
sie alle mit qr code wie im youtube buch
sehr gut ja und jetzt geht es dann von
mir aus dem foto zu machen auf den kampf
ist perfekt kragen sitzt super und
rechtliche schritte
und jetzt
also das praktische ist hier gibt es
zwar keine klingelschild steht ganz groß
dran wo man jeweils ist oder müsste mal
reparieren dass die wand weg
sowie das aber nicht unter 40 ist eine
riesen halle und eigentlich müsste es
jetzt total heilig sein aber ist es
nicht weil da oben da sieht man so graue
flächen da es in schall schlucken matten
und dadurch ist das hier so wie man ganz
normalen zimmer
so geht er dabei auch nicht guck mal
hier ist ja alles kaputt war er wie er
jetzt in welcher küche ist das ist die
küche vom scholz ja okay also
und volvo zu hier oder wer einfach da
wurden gefunden andere das ist aber mit
kongo hier noch ein bisschen
holz bemalt 7 aka nicht aus ist es aber
nicht dass die wg naja ok hier liebt
enzo
marcella
und sarah wir haben eine aufgeräumte
küche auf jeden fall eine wg ist es bei
dir auch so aufgeräumt also ich hab noch
schlimmer ach du liebe nach stimmt ja
schon lustig und es sieht ja wenn man
den blick rein wirft sieht das immer
echt aus als würde jemand wohnen das ist
ja auch das ziel nach den kenne ich auch
sie colosseo aber dabei glaube ich weiß
es gar nicht ich hab gerade so
hergezeigt ist es aber ist es ist sie
gut sieht glock
ingolf schöllner schauspieler
was haben wir denn jetzt hier das ist ja
irre
licht und jetzt kann ich hier zum
beispiel flur 11 4 könnte ich drücken
wenn ich mich draußen bereich markt
lieber nicht aber dann wäre zum rabatt
11 5 dann ist dann jeweils für sie da
oben sind ganz lampen und die wären
damit gesteuert
guckst du decke
josi ist die
wehr ist das einmal die enkelinnen nee
der ist ja schon mal stark von den start
die ältere tochter von den sportlern die
ältere tochter die aber irgendwo jetzt
in der aktuellen folgen so was die hat
sich nackt fotografieren lassen das ist
meine freunde nein das ist scheiße ich
wollte ja nicht zu nahe treten gleich zu
tal kam raus
jetzt scheiße das ist ja das ist meine
freunde okay diese auch wirklich blöd
wie kann man sowas machen tja also aber
kann dann passierte etwas das man
manchmal auf der straße als
orkan angesprochen wird heute das ich
werde mich also nicht dass werden
manchmal natürlich in dem sinne so immer
angelächelt aber er weiß ich dass die
genervt sind aber manche freuen sich
auch sehr gleich überhaupt dass jemand
mehr so eine rolle hat in der
lindenstraße der auch die leute bis hin
zum lachen bringt und auch ab und zu mal
unsinn ok go zone das ist hier ist eine
tür
guck mal hier so sieht ein
kleiderschrank in der lindenstraße aus
meine damen und herren
und wird sie nicht am rücken hier steht
wahrscheinlich ein pad oder sonst hallo
oder ihren schrank mit alex also ok
also wenn sie meine damen oder wenn sie
diesen kleiderschrank meine lindenstraße
sehen sie wissen das stimmt hinten und
vorn nicht weil wenn man jetzt hier
umgeht hsh mal sofort entdeckt steht ihr
ein schrank
das kann gar nicht stimmen und hier im
schrank kann man auch nicht durch das
sind klamotten dann könnt ihr nicht
durch die tür jetzt geben die man hier
noch sieht die aber diese ist hat
das ist
ja stimmt dann erstmal in anderen links
ach so na da hier rechts
nochmals um auffällige frisur okay na ja
genau setzt wir uns mal bei dem hin er
wird zum verzeihen hoffentlich auf jeden
fall super der lindenstraße kann man
sich wohlfühlen auf jeden fall ist eine
coole serie ist es kult was gibt es da
noch zu sagen das ist halt die die
lindenstraße ist die erste serie in
deutschland gewesen und der erste soap
die
sms
abfolge 3300 aber jetzt er auf jeden
fall ist es schon sehr sehr viel meine
damen ich habe den eindruck ich weiß
mehr über die lebensweise als er obwohl
ich sie kaum gucke und er ständig in ihr
spiel wir werden auch sowieso vielleicht
so machen dass er kann sein wird und ich
klicke übernehmen werde gerne auch mal
gucken wie es dann wird dann interview
ich die ganzen rapper oder schwer
abgesandt artisten wie man sie auch
nennt und er wird schauspieler und
spielt irgendwann mit angelina jolie
oder so
spaß bis dann bleib dran du
und wenn er beim gewinnspiel mitmachen
wollt passen zu meinem ersten auftritt
in der lindenstraße dann solltet ihr
euch das gewinnspiel video ansehen indem
es ein igel nagelneues ipad und die dvd
kollektion der lindenstraße zu gewinnen
gibt und den tag den ich mit kay one
dort gehabt habe den gibt es unter dem
titel one night stands nachts raus
schmeißen über das thema sprechen wir
nämlich unter diesem link also eins von
beiden könnte jetzt oder beide auch wie
ihr wollt könnt ihr jetzt auswählen
ansonsten bis dann